The first citizen astronaut crew safely splashed down off the coast of Florida on Saturday...
...after a three-day flight in SpaceX's Resilience spacecraft.
It was the first launch into Earth's orbit...
...without a career astronaut on board in an effort to ramp up space tourism.
Applause was heard from mission control...
...as the SpaceX capsule parachuted into calm seas shortly before sunset.
Within an hour, the four crew members were seen smiling,...
...emerging from the capsule's side hatch.
Each waved and gave a thumbs up to the cameras.
They were cheered again as they stepped onto the deck of the recovery ship.
The amateur astronauts were then flown by helicopter back to land...
...to reunite with loved ones.
On board Resilience was 29-year-old physician assistant...
...and childhood bone cancer survivor Haley Arsenault,...
...who became the youngest person to ever reach Earth's orbit.
Alongside her was a former NASA astronaut candidate,...
...an air force veteran and a billionaire who paid for the tickets, Jared Isaacman.
Their successful mission marked the debut flight of SpaceX's new astrotourism business.
Time Magazine estimates Isaacman paid roughly 200 million dollars...
...for the four spaceflight tickets.